un dragon et Jimon unsu merci beaucoup
Jimon d'être avec nous on va parler de
dragon 2 avec bien sûr ce film qui
concerne surtout les petits les grands
et toute la famille tu as accepté tout
de suite de faire la voix du méchant
dans Dragon 2 tu as dit oui tout de
suite tout de suite tout de suite vous
savez c'est le rêve plus ou moins de
tous les acteurs de de vouloir plus ou
moins apparaître dans un un
film animé spécialement si vous avez des
enfants j'ai un garçon qui va bientôt
avoir
5 ans et il était avec moi tout le temps
quand je j'allais au studio à dreamwks
enregistrer TR dragon donc c c'est un
grand plaisir pour lui d'être ici et
puis participer à la première aussi
avant les dragons nous posent quelques
petits problèmes mais aujourd'hui ils
sont venus vivre avec nous je t'ai dit à
quel point tu es belle aujourd'hui non
c'est vrai c'est un travail très
particulier de ne jouer qu'avec sa voix
pour un acteur physique comme tu es toi
ça demande une concentration
particulière oh absolument je trouvais
ça un peu beaucoup plus difficile dans
le sens que tu tu travailles tu
travailles avec un micro et tu as juste
ton réalisateur pour te guider plus ou
moins dans les de scène à scène pour
plus ou moins pour avoir une une idée de
plus ou moins ce que tu fais en volant
avec les dragons et tout ça tu joues le
le méchant physiquement il a des
balafres il est assez impressionnant tu
as tu as quoi tu tu as essayé de prendre
ta voix la plus grave tu as essayé de
donner beaucoup de essayé prend la voix
la plus grave j'ai essaie de trouver de
de de vraiment casser ma voix de souvent
plus ou moins essayer de trouver
drag